[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN MOORE: So whoever
is slicing and dicing
for publishing to YouTube, I
want to start not with my talk,
but with something that
Slava didn't point out.
I mean, his talk
was really funny.
You guys remember this slide?
I know we talked about,
this is not a pig's nose.
This is an outlet.
I was like, please,
he has to show--
it would have been so perfect.
This, of course, is the
problem with duck typing
and why we like strong types,
because not a good idea.
OK.
Now this is the
beginning of my talk.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
KEVIN MOORE: My
name is Kevin Moore,
proud resident of Seattle.
AUDIENCE: Woo.
KEVIN MOORE: And you
tell the Seattle people
by their muted statements.
Most of them are just
blinded by the sun outside,
so they're unable to
see that I'm talking.
You can find me.
I'm kevmoo everywhere.
I'm a product manager
on the Dart team,
and I help out with
the Angular packages
and the build packages
and generally just
the package ecosystem.
I care a lot about it.
Talk to Martin from
Denmark about how often I
send him random pull
requests for little things.
He's like, really?
Don't you have
anything better to do
than to fix the formatting
on Google API's off?
I was like, no!
It's not formatted!
It must be formatted.
So I care a lot about packages
and building good packages,
and that's the talk today.
This is the quiz.
So I want you guys all to
build amazing packages.
From the beginning,
Dart was open sourced.
We're an ECMA standard,
as Tim pointed out.
All of our code is on
GitHub, which we love.
And we want everyone else
to join us doing this.
We've done a bunch of work
to improve the package site.
We just launched the package
site December of last year.
Has anyone noticed that
we've updated the pub site?
Are you liking the new design?
Shout out to [? Isvan, ?]
if you're watching.
He did a bunch of great
work on the package site.
No, and the reason we
invest so much in this
is because we care
about community.
We realize we can't build
everything ourselves.
We want your help and people
watching at home-- your help
to build a great Dart ecosystem.
And so we need you
to go build packages.
And ideally, they'll
be amazing packages.
And so I'm here to
help you with that.
So this talk is three easy to
remember rules for perfect Dart
packages, which, of course--
now you might be
asking why I did this.
And the reason is there
is no bull emoticon.
There's a cow
emoticon, but I knew
there's the guys from
Iowa here, and they
can tell the difference.
So I went with an alternative.
I could have been classy and
done the cargo cult reference.
But I thought this is
more from where I'm from.
It's really difficult.
You know, it's
not simple-- there's no
simple three easy rules.
It's a lot of complex things.
But thankfully, we have a
lot of good documentation.
We have a lot of great tools.
And today, I'm here to tell
you about some of those.
So let's start with the basics.
And obviously, the first
one is, don't panic.
You know, there are a lot of
things to think about here.
It's like writing good code.
There's no simple recipe.
But we try to hold your hand
through a lot of the things.
Just spend some time reading the
documentation, using the tools
we've given you, and you'll
have a lot of success.
In fact, if you go into
IntelliJ or, I'm sure,
VS Code and you go, New Dart
Project or New Flutter Project,
we do a very good job of
making sure we set you up
with a canonical package with
things in the right directories
and the right files you need--
the right entries
in your pubspec.
In some cases, you need to
go and uncomment the line.
But we try to set you up for
success from the beginning.
The second piece of
advice is, find a friend.
Bob made a comment
earlier that it's
so much easier emceeing
with someone else on stage,
and I totally agree.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KEVIN MOORE: Ah.
You can ask him
later what he said.
So having someone to
work with you on anything
is really nice,
especially with a package.
You know, I occasionally
will write a bug,
and so having someone review
the code is kind of nice,
to make sure I catch
myself with bad formatting.
And obviously, as a
package gets more popular,
you get to deal with
issues and pull requests.
Like, people find
things that are broken
or people want new features.
And so having someone to work
with to handle the issues
and the pull requests is
a great way to make sure
you find success.
And so don't go it alone.
Find a friend, if you can.
And use best practices.
We spent a lot of
time-- actually,
Bob has done a bunch
of work on this.
Cathy and a number of others--
creating a good set of
really good guidelines
and documentation around just
good ways to write Dart code.
Go read them.
We have an effective Dart guide.
And the two rules
here are actually,
you know, great
things to start with.
Consistent and brief, in
general, is really good.
This is an amazing document.
It's actually a
relatively quick read,
and just gives you good things
to think about, in terms
of how do you name classes?
How do you name methods?
Those coming from C Sharp--
where is Tim sitting?
You know, methods
are capital cased,
and so how do you make sure
you do those things correctly?
We cover all of that.
When should I use
positional arguments
versus named arguments?
These are just good
things to keep in mind,
and we have really good dockets
to go through a lot of it.
We also have conventions
about package layout.
So when you're thinking
about publishing a package,
where do I put my library code?
Where do I put my tests?
We have it all documented.
It's really accessible.
This is a great place to start.
And so, as I said,
the tools we give you
in IntelliJ and VS
Code and other places
will set you up
with good defaults.
But we also have
great docs here.
And finally, follow
framework conventions.
So a simple example here--
in Angular, we
generally say you name
whatever your component is--
XYZ component.
In Flutter, you don't.
So even though you're
extending widget,
you don't call yourself
the XYZ widget.
And so this is a little thing.
You know, the only
recommendation
here is spend time
reading the code
of the thing you're extending.
Kind of get an idea
for the conventions
there on how you name
methods-- how you name classes.
This will help all of
your users because really,
when you build an application
or build a package,
you want to make sure
that it fits nicely
in to the existing ecosystem.
So follow any framework
conventions that exist.
And that's the basics.
Tying your shoes.
So, once you have a
package all put together,
let's talk about publishing.
Again, guess what?
We have a guide on this that
tells you what you need.
So read the docs.
It's good before you create a
package and name 1,000 files
and put imports and everything
that you actually make
sure your package is available.
We have this amazing online
tool to help you figure out
if a package is available.
It's called a 404.
We should really file an issue--
this is a good pull request,
if someone wants to contribute.
Make a funnier 404 if a
package isn't available.
But we can see that the
package isn't available there,
so I can go publish.
And again, if we
do a Pub publish,
we give you a lot
of good advice here.
So pay attention to
what Pub tells you
if publish doesn't
immediately work.
And then there are actually
some cases where it will say,
are you sure you
want to publish?
It'll actually give you a
bunch of warnings and errors.
It'll tell you if you're missing
an import or if you have too--
I think it won't tell you if
you have too many imports,
but at least it will tell you
if you have a missing import.
So pay attention to
this information.
It's really useful.
And it will tell
you what's required.
And again, what you realize
is you should have read
the docs in the first place.
You'd have been much better off.
The next thing is versioning,
and this gets a little tricky.
What's great about
Dart-- at least, what
I find really
great about Dart is
if I'm using
someone's data type--
let's say there's actually
a semver package here.
So I'm using the
version type from that.
I know that the
version I'm using--
if I'm using 15
other packages that
have to be used in
the version type,
they're all the
same version type.
In other platforms that
will remain unnamed,
you don't have that certainty.
So the fact that you have
one version of these classes
is really useful.
But that means you have
to think about versioning
and how this all works.
And so if I were to give you
any advice about thinking
about versioning versus
for the things you use,
make sure you specify a version
range for everything you use.
And I'm pretty sure
Pub-- is Natalie--
Natalie is here, right?
Pub won't let you publish
unless you have lower
and upper constraints, right?
You must specify
a range and say,
these are the range
of things I use.
AUDIENCE: It'll just
give you a warning.
KEVIN MOORE: Oh,
We should make that an error.
Yeah, because if you say, oh,
I support anything greater
than 2, it's like, sure?
Are you sure that
version 3, version 4
that have never
been invented-- you
will be compatible with those?
You don't know.
So make sure you do
a full range-- lower
and upper constraint.
Be conservative about these.
Unless you've used
that version before,
make sure you
constrain it and you
don't claim to support every
version of a package that
ever has been or ever will be.
And finally, be careful when
you update your version string.
This is really
important, and we'll
talk about maintenance
a little bit later.
But it can cause
a lot of problems.
If you release a breaking
change and you call it a plus 1,
anyone who uses
your package might
do Pub upgrade and
get that version,
and cause lots of issues.
I think even the Dart
team, on occasion,
has been guilty of this.
It's a tricky thing to do.
The only thing I can say
is, going back to the point
about having a friend,
these are good things
to be sanity checked
before you hit Publish.
So let's do a quiz quick.
We have a lot of people who
have used Dart for a while.
Natalie, you're not allowed
to answer these because she
wrote the version solver.
That's cheating.
OK, so I have a version
constraint here.
Hat, 1.1.0.
Now don't yell out,
but think to yourself,
which versions are contained
in that version range?
All right?
I stumped someone
yesterday-- a Googler.
It was funny.
Is that what you got?
Oh!
So hat, 1.1.0 means
anything greater than
or equal to 1.1.0 and
anything less than 2.0.
So this is a great shorthand.
And again, once you want to
support many breaking change
versions of a package, it's
actually a nice shorthand.
You know that once you
move beyond hat syntax
and you have to do
greater than or equal to,
you're in a little
bit of scary territory
because that means
you're actually
defining a range that
spans major versions-- that
might span breaks.
And so now you know you
need to be extra careful.
And I knew Natalie was going
to be here, and I was scared.
So I actually wrote
the code to make sure
that the answer was correct, for
fear that she would call me out
later.
So here's the next question.
Let's say I depend on
the foo package, at that.
And I do Pub upgrade.
And Now, no asterisk here.
There's no other package that
depends on foo-- just this one
package.
What version do I get?
And here's one answer,
so yell it out.
AUDIENCE: 1.2.
KEVIN MOORE: 1.2.
By default, when you're
using the Pub client,
we won't get non-full released
versions of a package.
So even though this, in theory,
would go get 1.3.0, full stop,
it won't get the
pre-release version.
This way, we make sure that
when we go get packages for you,
we get you stable versions
of those packages.
And of course, you could always
use a dependency override
or be explicit and say, I
want 1.3.0 beta or whatever,
if you're testing.
We're doing some
of these tricks now
with the Angular packages
because we're pre-release.
But in general, you'll
only get stable versions.
So if you do Pub upgrade and
you see that, oh, there's
a version available and
it's dash alpha something,
you know why.
So if you want to understand
more about versioning in Dart,
and again, if you're
new to it, semver
is a great spec
we try to follow.
I will say there's one to
do in semantic versioning.
We had an email exchange
about this yesterday,
which is they're vague about
ordering, intentionally.
There are flavors of versions
that the semver spec says,
there is no known
or no approved way
to think about versioning these.
We think that's really broken.
We actually think that
determinism is kind of nice,
so the way Pub implements
version ranking and ordering,
we are deterministic.
So we're a little bit
off the semver spec.
But every place in
the Dart ecosystem
where we handle versions--
version solving,
version ranges, all the ordering
is handled by this package.
And so if you're curious
about how that works
or how we-- the small
deltas we have from semver,
you can look at Pub semver.
So that's the stuff
in your Pub spec.
What about other files?
There's a number
of files we want.
A lot of them are
markdown files.
You have to have a read me.
You can make it look pretty.
I'll give an example in a bit.
Please have a change log.
It helps people
keep track of what
you've done in your release.
Even if you do a
minor release for,
like, internal plumbing
reasons, just put
a change log entry that says,
changed internal plumbing.
It's really helpful
for folks to understand
how things have changed.
If your code is on GitHub,
please use a contributing .md
file.
This file will actually be
linked any time anyone opens
an issue or a pull request,
and it will tell them
how to file an issue, what
should be included in issues,
what process should they go
through when they do a pull
request.
Just a great kind of thing to
do to encourage contributions.
And recently, with
the new Pub role,
we actually now
support example files.
So this is the simplest
example, and there's
a few other formats we support.
But if you actually
add an example file
to the approved, conventional
example directory,
we actually render
that in a tab.
So let me show you
an example of that.
So here is the video player
Flutter plug-in slash package.
A few things-- you notice
it has a great change log.
Well done.
It does not have a gratuitous
and redundant change log
title in the top of
the change log file
because we know
it's the change log.
Yes, I'm digging at people who
consistently add the change log
header to change log files.
You'll notice that
in the Versions tab,
we show all the versions
that have been uploaded.
And look.
They actually have
perfect correlation.
They've done the work to
make sure that everything
is lined up here, except wait.
Are they missing one?
No, it looks pretty good.
I think they did a good job.
You'll see that the example
file was rendered here
with pretty code
coloring, which is great.
And really quick, let me
just go to the GitHub source,
and let's look at
the raw read me file.
And these are a
few little things
that aren't discussed a
lot, so use markdown syntax.
Really try to use the
triple tick syntax.
Let me even zoom in
a little bit bigger.
For some reason,
people still like
to use the four space
indentation for code.
One, keeping track
of the indentation
and if you have
code blocks, it's
just a miserable thing to do.
And then you can't
specify the language.
So if you actually do triple
tick XML or triple tick Dart,
you get pretty formatting,
not only on GitHub, but also
on the package site.
So use triple ticks, please.
So read the friendly manuals
on how to publish packages.
Spend some time
understanding versioning.
Format your markdown,
and use examples.
Now, maintaining a package.
Let's go look at the video
player one more time.
Oops.
Click on the link.
There we go.
So this is a new feature
of the package site.
I don't know if people
have noticed this.
Packages now have a score.
Dun, dun, dun.
So your score is comprised
of three things--
your popularity, your
health, and your maintenance.
Popularity-- I'm not
going to tell you
how we do it because
any system can be gamed.
The only thing you
should keep in mind
is the more people
that use your package
and depend on your
package, the more popular
your package will be.
Health is basically a measure
of mostly static analysis.
So if you run Dart
Analyze over your package,
if Dart Analyze comes back with
few or no warnings and errors,
you have a higher health.
We do run Analyzer
in Strong Mode,
and so if you haven't
already enabled
Strong Mode in your package--
added analysis options--
you should because we're
judging you on this.
We want to encourage people
to move to the future--
move to Dart 2 and Strong Mode.
And the maintenance is a
number of other things around.
Do you have a change log?
Let's see what else is in there.
Change log is what I remember.
How often have you
updated your package?
And actually, this
is mostly around
if your package
hasn't been updated
or any package hasn't been
updated in over a year,
you start losing points, and
it descends to 0 at two years.
So if you haven't touched
your package in two years,
it will have a maintenance of 0.
So if you're looking
to use packages,
you should go look
at these scores.
Obviously, a package
that is brand new
might have-- and make
sure you highlight
if it's been less than 30
days since it's been created.
It might not have
a lot of users.
But you can also differentiate
between a package that hasn't
been updated in a year or two.
We've been around
for a long time.
Every packaged ecosystem
has a little bit of rot.
We try to make sure that
we keep you away from that.
And obviously, when you
search in the package site,
we make sure that we basically
rank, not only by your search
results, but also by a
combination of these factors,
so that we try to
give you the best--
not only a good match
for what you gave,
but a package that's
high quality, popular,
and has been maintained.
And one final note I wanted
to bring up here is pana.
So we actually have a package
that we publish called pana.
It's short for package analyzer.
This is what happens
when I name a package.
But it's the underlying
infrastructure
for how we measure health and
some aspects of maintenance.
So one second here.
You can install pana.
So if you go to Pub,
global activate, pana,
it'll install the pana package.
And then you can run pana over
a package you get to publish,
and figure out its score.
There might be a
few little nuances
around Flutter packages.
Try it out on Flutter packages.
If you have issues, let me know.
One little interesting caveat
is that we actually go in
and we modify the Pub spec
file and your analysis file--
just your Pub spec file on disk.
The reason we do that
is we want to do--
when we do a version
solving, we want
to make sure that
we don't factor
in your dev dependencies, in
terms of what you depend on.
So you can turn off
the no warning thing.
Make sure your code is committed
into Git before you do this.
We'll clean up the file when
we're done, but just FYI.
But this is a great way,
before you publish a package,
to see what would my health be.
And again, if you're already
using our tools-- you're using,
you know, VS Code, IntelliJ,
you're running the formatter,
you should be in pretty
good shape already.
But this will give you
kind of a very long JSON
output explaining
exactly how we think
about the health
of your package.
So beyond just general
code maintenance, you know,
everyone makes mistakes.
This is one of the reasons
I love working in software
is because issues like
this-- you get used to,
OK, get, reset head.
And you can go back.
Your boss doesn't need to
know unless you published.
But aside from, obviously,
having your friend--
someone to help you with
code reviews and things,
use the tools.
Test your stuff.
Again, Natalie here--
really, just the whole talk
is owed to Natalie.
She did so much work here.
We have a great test package.
We recommend you use it.
It's the same test package
we use for, you know,
low level shared libraries
and the web and on Flutter.
It works really great.
You use Pub run test
on the test package.
We have static analysis
tools that work great.
Use the analyzer.
We have a great formatter.
You can run it in line.
You can run it
inside the editors.
It works great.
Well, I know we talked about
conventions a little bit.
Just, like, agreeing on
formatting is so useful.
I have yet to see anyone give
me an example of a line of code
that was, like, a
bespoke formatting that
was worth not being
able to just not think
about whitespace arguments
and code reviews.
Right?
No?
Really?
Come on.
Like, no arguments
about whitespace--
like, the times I spent arguing
about whitespace and code
reviews.
Like, just use the
formatter, please.
Bob has better style
than anybody here.
And once you have all
those things gold--
you have-- you're
analyzing your test,
then use continuous integration.
We use a lot of Travis
for Linux testing,
and it supports some Mac.
AppVeyor is available
for Windows testing.
It's really simple.
Put that in the .Travis file.
You're good to go.
And in fact, let me give
you a demo real quick.
So I have a package
here called peanut.
The trick is really fun.
I think it will run
Pub build or Pub build
against a package on
your system on your disk,
And it'll do the work to
check out your GH Pages branch
and commit everything
to GH Pages.
But you don't have to,
like, check it out yourself.
And then you can just push
your GH Pages branch to GitHub
and you have your GH Page thing.
There are three people
here who've done GH Pages,
and everyone else is like,
what are you talking about?
It's cool.
Trust me.
Ask me afterwards.
But I get to enable
testing on this--
Travis.
So let's do that quick.
So you see I have
source code here.
I didn't increase my font
size before giving a talk.
Actually, even better
to go to the console.
That's better.
Here is a Travis file I'm
just going to add to my repo.
Before I add it to
my repo, though, I
want to enable
Travis on the site.
So basically, it's
a find and replace.
Travis-ci.org.
You'll see Travis has not been
activated yet for this package,
so let's do that.
Travis is enabled.
A couple little tricks
here that I really like--
you can say only build
if there's a Travis file.
Whatever.
This is something I've really
pushed on the Dart team a lot,
and I encourage you to do it.
Travis now supports cron jobs.
So it'll rerun the tests on the
last master branch or whatever
as often as you want.
I generally do once a week.
What's great about this
is now, if you have--
obviously, you guys have
dependencies on packages.
Likely.
Those packages might be revving.
You might say, I want to depend
on the stable of the dev, SDK.
You know, that Google
is revving Dart often.
And what this makes
sure is even if you
haven't touched the package in
a while, the test will be rerun.
And if the Dart SDK
has been updated
or any of your
dependencies have updated,
your test will still be rerun.
And it's amazing, even
those e-mails-- like, oh.
Someone else you depend on has
broken the version constraint
contract, and now you
know who to go blame.
But this actually tracks
well what your users will
go through, as well.
So use cron jobs in Travis.
It's really nice.
Then I can just go into
here and go get push.
In theory, I should
do a pull request.
But again, I have no one
helping me with peanut.
If someone wants
to help me and be
my friend on the peanut package,
that would be much easier.
And let's push.
Drum roll.
Now if I go into Travis and I
hit reload and I hit reload,
ah.
And there's the first build--
running the test for peanut
on Dart stable and Dart dev.
This is another great trick.
If you care about supporting
older versions of Dart,
you can specify
the version ranges.
Works really great.
So that's Travis support.
Again, there's great
docs for Travis.
If you just search for,
like, Travis docs Dart,
there's great documentation
about how that all works.
[COUGHING]
Excuse me.
And besides that, we just have
a great collection of tools.
So our analysis also supports
a number of customizable Lints.
There's the website
for the Linter.
Phil's done a bunch of
work on the Linter package,
and these are great.
This is like Dart formatting
in my world, which is like, oh.
You know, we care about
if you order, you know,
the import directives.
You have some argument
in the code review.
Please order the-- no, just
have that Linter do it.
You know, no, you're
using single space
and really it should be double--
single quotes.
You should be using
double quotes.
Like, no, no, no.
Like, we'll just
use single quotes.
That's the way we're doing
it and it'll just work.
And so it really gets rid of a
lot of those kind of arguments
and also just makes your
code more consistent,
and it helps you find bugs.
Like, we'll actually
statically figure out
if the regex you put in a
string is a valid regex.
So you don't find
out at runtime.
There are dozens of Lints.
They're being
added all the time.
Check out the Linter.
Isn't this the most fun error
you get when you do Pub?
You don't get the latest
version of Quiver,
and you don't know why.
This drove me completely insane.
And so I made a little
tool to help with it.
It's called PubViz.
Basically visualizes
your Pub dependencies.
It's also played
to graphviz, which
is the technology I use here,
and you get this crazy thing.
This is why you
get a 4 K monitor.
You can see it all.
It works really nicely.
So again, I talked about--
there's trade offs.
You know, inside Google, there's
many articles discussing that.
We have one version
of every package,
and it makes a lot of things
easy and a lot of things
really hard.
And so, obviously, in
the open source world,
you get to think about how
version constraints work.
It can be a problem.
I think it's great because
it enables an ecosystem that
actually is based on knowing
the dependencies you're using
and having consistent
dependencies.
But you can zoom in here.
There's a Zoom In
button so you can
look to see how things work.
You can actually hover over
on a package to see, oh, like,
who's using that?
I print out in the console
dump in the Chrome.
You can actually go look
and see the output there.
So you can figure
out what's used what
and figure out why Quiver's not
being updated to the latest.
It works really nice.
A final idea for a tool--
often we have
constellations of packages,
and so examples here
are the build tool.
We have a number of packages
we want to work on together.
We tend to rev them and
work on them as one chunk.
Angular is another example.
We have the Angular compiler and
forms and routing and the AST
package.
We bring these all in together.
We want to manage
these as one repository
with one set of tests.
It makes things much easier.
So again, we have a
tool Called mono repo.
And what this helps
to do is manage
that set of or
that constellation
of packages in one repo.
And so an example of a command
you can run is mono Travis.
And what you do is you actually
put a .Travis file in each
sub-repo, and you use the
format I described earlier.
Analyze tests.
You can customize
it if you want,
and then mono repo will go
through in each sub-directory--
the .Travis files,
and create a global,
top-level Travis file
and a shell script.
So it will run
all those packages
as though they're each
individually configured.
So you don't have
to become a bash
expert to configure multiple
packages in one Git repo.
And it just works.
And so we use this across
a number of our packages.
If you want to [? bait ?] a mono
repo and put a bunch of code
in one repo, but have
separate packages,
mono repo is a good helper.
So that's maintaining, you know.
You can look at your
score on the package site
and run pana locally
before you publish.
Make sure you test.
We have a great test
package for that.
And Travis and
other CI solutions
are a great way to make
sure you maintain quality.
And also, it's a great
way to help contributions
because when they
send pull requests,
they get tested
before they're run.
So like, I'm not going to
tell you what you did wrong.
But go look at Travis.
Get Travis green,
then we'll talk.
And of course, we have
a bunch of tools that
will help you along the way.
So I want you all to go build
Dart packages and Flutter
packages.
But build them great.
And we give you a bunch of docs
and tools to help with that.
I know I've gone through
a lot of content here.
Don't worry.
This video will be on YouTube.
I will put a link
in the description
below, if you want to see links
to the things I discussed--
the tools I discussed here.
And go build great
Dart packages.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]